so when you recognize that Tech affects
the technology when utilized
effects patterns of human behavior
humans now do the thing they do with the
text so people do this thing and they
didn't used to do this thing right on
the cell phone or whatever
um
to utila to get the benefits of the tech
you have a totally different pattern of
human behavior as a result you have
different nature of mind
um you have different value systems that
emerge and it becomes obligate or some
version of a compensatory attack becomes
obligate because the Amish are not
really shaping the world they're no
longer engaged in the great power
competition
I have a bone to pick there I had
watched a few months ago and I don't
know anything about them or didn't know
anything about the Amish and I'm just
someone who grew up in this city and so
I dismissed them as luddites like we've
used that term several times and they're
backward they don't know what they're
talking about and then I watched a video
the Amish aren't idiots they're not
asinine there's a reason why they do
what they do and they either explicitly
or intuitively understand that the
technology changes the social dynamics
in the way that they view the world and
totally and has ethical considerations
so but that influenced me that
influenced perhaps millions of people
because it's a video I think it has a
few million hits even if they're local
just them saying you know what I don't
care I'm going to continue to act right
it can still influence outward anyway
and we're talking about it now maybe
this will influence people and hopefully
to something positive and I hopefully to
myself something positive
yeah
okay so it's not that you come to this a
few times which is even if you have a
meme Plex that is not that doesn't
become part of the dominant system can
it infect or influence the mean Plex in
a way that stiff steers it yes
but one does not want to be naive about
how much influence that's going to have
they want to be thoughtful about exactly
how that'll work and what kinds of
influences we mentioned not all of
Buddhism got picked up everywhere right
like the parts that had to do with
um why people should take values of
poverty and live on very little that
didn't really get picked up the parts on
how to reduce stress
got picked up the parts on what a
healthy motive is didn't get picked up
as much as the parts on how to empower
your motive through a more functional
mind so it's important to get that the
memes might live in a complex in a
context when they influence
parts of them are going to interact with
another meme Plex and the technoplex and
everything else and so
you are right to say that it's not that
they have no influence
but obviously the Amish and not speaking
to that they're dumb and backwards but
that in their
don't want to engage tech for these
reasons arguments they don't have a
significant say in whether we engage a
particular nuclear war or not
or they were not the ones that
overfished the ocean cause species
Extinction but they also couldn't stop
it
right they are not the ones that are
creating synthetic biology that can make
totally new species
so
the and this is why I say there is a
naive techno optimism that focuses on
the upsides and doesn't focus on all the
end order effects and downsides
and as we were just mentioning the
externalities of tech are not just
physical right you do this mining to get
the thing you want but there's a lot of
mining pollution or the herbicide does
make farming easier in this way but it
harms the environment and human health
in this other way that's physical
externalities but you also get these
psychosocial externalities you use
Facebook for this purpose and it ends up
eroding democracy and doubling down on
biased increasing addiction and body
dysmorphia and things like that right so
the tech affects not it doesn't it has
effects that are not the ones you
intended some of which might be positive
you can have a positive externality but
it might have a lot of negative
externalities
and those negative externalities can
Cascade second third fourth order
effects so there's a naive techno
optimism that doesn't pay enough
attention to that there's a naive
technopessimism that says well I'm aware
of those negative externalities I don't
want those for our people we think we
can isolate our people from everybody
else and say we're going to not do that
but we're going to have decreased
influence over what everyone who is
doing that has
right which is what then some of the AI
or Labs argue is there's an arms race we
can't stop the arms race on it and so
only being at the front of the arms race
can we steer it I would argue that that
is a naive version of that particular
thing but nonetheless
so
um if we want to you know and one way of
reading
um
one of the problematic lessons of the
elves in Tolkien
is and I'm just making this as like a
toy model
is in some ways they figured out how to
have a nicer life than the humans and
dwarves and whatever else they were able
to do radical life extension and figure
out great GDP per capita where the
poorest people were doing well and they
were so kind of but they became insular
because they were so disenchanted with
the world of men and elves and whatever
they're like it we're just going to
kind of isolate and do our own thing our
own way but it ends up being that you're
still all sharing Middle Earth and the
problem somewhere else can Cascade into
catastrophic problems that end up
messing up your world too so you can't
be isolationist in it forever in an
interconnected world so they actually
had to they were kind of obligated if we
rewrote the story to take whatever they
had learned and try to help everybody
else have it or have enough of it that
you didn't get
um work dominance and stuff like that so
basically arguing that a isolationist we
see a problem we're going to avoid that
for ourselves
doesn't work with planetary problems
and so I'm not interested in the naive
techno negative versions that say
because we see a problem with tech we're
not going to do it but we're also going
to kind of load a seat in the process
and not engage with the fact that we
actually care about what happens for the
world overall and we have to engage with
how the world as a whole is doing
nothing
makes sense what I mean by the naive
techno pessimism
and
it is that
you you do not get to do effective
isolationism on an interconnected planet
that is hitting planetary boundaries
with exponential Tech
yeah I guess what I'm trying to express
is that even the Amish with what they're
doing it's not as simple as the meme
Flex that's exported by the Amish is the
Amish meme Plex there's something else
that even influenced them even yourself
you may be in a position that saves
Earth at least for now from a hugely
catastrophic event same with the odd cow
skin same with some others but what
influenced you there's some good in you
hopefully that was influenced by
something else by something else that's
good which also influenced the Amish
each person is corrupt in some way so
I'm saying that there's something that's
like the unity of Virtues that
influences us and that as long as we go
back and we think or constantly we're
assessing ourselves and saying is what
I'm doing good then these other meme
plexes that are being thrown to us and
yes it's in a different context somehow
it can Orient and pick up the good
I we're completely on the same page
which is that that
happens does not always happen and that
that is a important thing to have happen
but if that happened
adequately or at the
yeah I will say adequately then we
wouldn't have extinct all the species
that we have we would not have turned as
many old growth forests into deserts we
would not have had as many
um genocides and unnecessary Wars and
Etc so seeing the failure and where
either someone's definition of good is
too narrow
get our God to win and everybody
else or grow GDP and they'll take care
of everything we can well intendedly
pursue a definition of good that's too
narrow and externalize harm
unintentionally
we can pursue a definition of good that
we really believe in that other people
don't believe in and our answer is to
win over them but it creates an arms
race where now we're in competition over
the thing
or where there are people who are really
not pursuing the good of all even
they're not even trained to read there's
a whether it's sociopathy from a head
injury or genes or trauma or whatever it
is they are pursuing
a different thing right but they're good
at acquiring power
and this is actually a very important
thing is uh
that the
psychologies that are that want power
and are good at getting it
and the psychologies that would be the
best stewards of power for the
well-being of all are not the same set
of psychological attributes
they're pretty close to inversely
correlated
so those types of things have to be
calculated in this so what you're saying
right now which is great no matter what
you're saying it is that there is some
ought impulse that is not only in their
symbols right that you're calling a
universal virtue or good or something
and you're saying that some people feel
very called by that and that that's uh
important I agree completely now
um
where why is that historically and
currently not a strong enough binding is
the important question why has that not
been a strong enough binding for all the
species that are extinct and all the
animals in factory farms and all the
disruption Etc and then what would it
take for it to become a strong enough
binding or the nature of the question
here right that's actually at the heart
of the metacrisis question
is to have like what is a system of art
that is actually commensurable what the
system of is
and what is a way of having that
uh actually
sufficiently influence behavior such
that the catastrophic behaviors don't
occur
um and that the nature of the influence
is not so top down that it becomes
dystopic
and that's something like is there
either a so one way of thinking about
this is um I've mentioned the term a
couple times superstructure social
structure infrastructure that comes from
Marvin Harris's work on cultural
materialism basically saying every
civilization
you can think of in those ways what is
it's kind of meme Plex what is its
social coordination strategies and what
is the physical tooling said upon which
it depends and
different social theorists will say
which of these they think is most
fundamental the value systems are
ultimately what steer behavior and
determine the types of tech we build and
the types of societies religious
thinkers think there right
um Enlightenment fingers think there
the social system actually whatever you
incentivize financially is what's going
to win
um because whether it's good or not the
people who do that get the money can
incentivize more people create the law
Etc so ultimately the most powerful
thing is the social coordination systems
and then the other schools of thought
say no actually the thing that changes
in time the most is the tech and the
tech influences the patterns of human
behavior values everything else
and so and that's actually what Marvin
Harris roughly was saying was that
um the change in the tech Plex is ended
up being the most influential thing to
the change in because it does affect
worldviews and it does affect social
systems in the way we already mentioned
that the change of the tech Plex of the
printing press affected both World Views
and soup and social system so did the
plow so did the internet so it was about
to be AI
um I would argue that these three are
interacting with each other in complex
ways they all in turn from each other
and what we have to think about is
what changes in all three of them
simultaneously factoring all the
feedback loops produce a virtuous cycle
that orients in a direction that isn't
catastrophes or dystopias is the right
way of thinking about it
and ultimately
the direction actually has to be
the superstructure
informing the social structure
informing or guide buying direct the
infrastructure sorry can you repeat that
once more
yeah the right now
especially post-industrial Revolution
physical technology infrastructure had
way faster feedback loops on it than the
others did right
and because of that it started breaking
the previous like industrial era Tech
at massive scales with those extra
knowledge whatever can't be managed by
agrarian era or hunter-gatherer era
World Views and political systems right
so we ended up getting a whole new set
of political systems both Nation
democratic
um liberal democracies and capitalism
and social communism emerging as writing
the Industrial Revolution and what
should be the political economy that
governs that thing right
um
but the feedback loops from
Tech and specifically whether it's a
nation-state caught in multi-polar traps
that's building the tech in a central
government communist type place or a
market building it but that has perverse
incentives built into what its incentive
structure is
um that has influence on our social
structures and our cultures
superstructures
that we could say the dominance of that
direction is one way of thinking about
the driver of the meta crisis
now
the other direction
if we are to say no these examples of
the attack won't be built or we're not
going to use the tech in these ways
right we're not going yes you can use a
tech that extracts some parts of rocks
from other parts of rocks that gives us
metal we want but also gives a lot of
waste no you can't put all that waste in
the Waterway right
um or you can't put that pollution there
or you can't cut all the trees down in
that area we're calling it a national
park right that law or regulation that
is not just a tech thing that's the
social layer so that layer has to bind
the tech and guide and direct it say
these applications and not these ones
yeah
right yep but if the social system
is not an instantiation if the social
structure is not the sensation of the
superstructure it's not an instantiation
of the will of the people then it will
be oppressive
right which is why the idea of democracy
emerged out of the idea of the
Enlightenment which was this was a kind
of governance that only worked for a
comprehensively educated and you read
all the founding uh documents that the
comprehensive education had to be is and
ought right it said you must have a
moral education as well as a scientific
education and you must be schooled in
the science of governance
and only a people like that going back
what we said earlier couldn't check the
government right could both know the
jurisprudence to instantiate what is
good law could engage in dialectics to
to listen to other people's point of
view to come up with Democratic answers
um so it was the idea that there was a
kind of superstructure possibility which
was some kind of Enlightenment or era
values it could make a type of social
structure that could both utilize the
tech and guide it but also bind its
disruptive applications
so when you're saying isn't there some
super structure isn't there some sense
of good that will make us bind our
capacities
I would argue that if the sense of good
doesn't emerge from the collective
understanding and will of the people but
is instantiated in government because we
the technocrats know the right answer or
we the enlightened or the right answer
that will be oppressive and people are
right to be concerned by it
but if the collective understanding is I
want what I want I don't care what the
effects are or those guys over
there or I'm not paying attention to
externalities or whatever then the
collective will of the people is too
dumb to govern
and misguided to govern exponential Tech
and will self-terminate
so you cannot have
a
a uneducated unevolved set of values in
a Libertarian way guide exponential Tech
well right it has to be more considerate
has to Think Through end order effects
but you also can't have a government
that says we are the enlightened ones
and we figured it out and we're going to
impose it on everyone else without it
being oppressive and tyrannical which
means nothing less than a kind of
cultural Enlightenment is required long
term
so that the collective will of the
people now this gets back to the
alignment topic is the will of the
people aligned with itself actually
right is what I want factoring the
effects of what I want the end order
effects which means how other people
will respond to that and all that comes
from it is what I want actually even
aligned with a viable future
right
and so that is when we're talking about
getting in line alignment right
alignment with my intention where my
intention is that my country wins at all
costs where then China's like well
we're going to do the same thing or
Russia et cetera so you get arms races
that intent or my intent is I want more
stuff and keep up with the Joneses and
I'm not paying attention to planetary
boundaries
those intents are not aligned with their
own fulfillment because the world
self-terminates for too long in that
process
and so with the power of exponential
Tech and the cumulative effects of
industrial Tech
we do have to actually get
ought that can bind the power that is
and it can't be imposed it does have to
be emergent which does mean something
like that sense that you're saying has
to become
very Universal and nurtured right and
then has to also instantiate itself in
Reformation of systems of governance
I love what you said let's see if I can
recapitulate it there's Tech at the
bottom there's a social structure here
and then there's culture okay so these
are people up here there's people in all
three there's people's values up here
values so values are up here and then
there's the social structure over here
and then there's Tech over here okay so
currently the tech influences the way
our society is structured which also
influences our values and a part of the
meta crisis is saying that that's upside
down but it shouldn't just be whatever
values that just get imposed onto the
social structure the values have to
somehow come from someplace else and
then the mystics have their other they
have to be coherent with reality sure so
the spiritual people may call this
something akin to God and the
enlightenment people may say I don't
know maybe there's some evolutionary
will that comes out and if we just close
our eyes and hope for the best somehow
that emerges whatever it's called it's
not entirely us it's not our entirely
our conscious selves the conscious self
would be the more humanistic the
enlightenment way of thinking about it
is that we can impose a their own values
unless Nietzsche had something similar
to this so I like this I'm in agreement
with it I think we've just been using
different terminology
you and I both know that
um
when you
in many ways
I have to say this
and
evolution of cultural world view and
values adequate to Steward the power of
exponential technology and
non-catastrophic or non-dystopic ways
is happening in some areas but a regress
is also happening in some areas
right there is increasing
um Left Right polarization
I thought you're going to say there's a
regress happening like in demand so for
instance we generally think like it has
to be malthusian and the more that we
use the more the demand for that
increases and that's obviously removing
some of the more scarce objects like art
and gold which their value comes from
scarcity but there is like the largest
Health Trend right now is fasting it's
like we've gotten so much food that
we're like let's just not have any food
and then there's also recycling let's
just imagine that we think about
recycling at all so there is some
recognition that hey look we're
consuming too much let's cut back and so
it's not purely just an exponential
function it is we take into account the
rate of production
well so what we can see is that
the percentage of the total let's go
ahead and say U.S but we could look at
UAE or Nigeria or whatever various
places the percent of the U.S
population
that is regularly doing fasting is still
a relatively small percentage
and in the same way that like it is true
that when there's a market race to the
bottom that we saw in food which Hostess
and McDonald's you know Etc kind of want
which is how do we make the food
uh more and more combinations of salt
fat and sugar and texture and
palatability that maximize kind of
stickiness and addiction which of course
if I have a fiduciary responsibility to
shareholder maximization and the key to
that is to optimize the lifetime value
of a customer addiction is awesome right
um it's actually not awesome it's
legally obligate because of maximize
shareable returns
um so that created a race to the bottom
or rather than starvation being the
leading cause of death obesity was the
leading cause of health-related death in
the west okay well that bottom of the
race to the bottom also creates a race
to the top for a different Niche so then
Whole Foods becomes the fastest growing
supermarket and biohacking and Etc
so that's true did that affect the
overall population demographics
regarding obesity very significantly not
really
um did it stop the race to the bottom no
it just added another little niche race
which also then separated which created
more class system separation
so it's not that those effects don't
happen
are they happening at the scale and
speed necessary when we look at
catastrophic risks so of course I can
also pay more for a post-consumer
recycled thing and there is more
recycling happening
but there's also more net extraction of
raw resources and more net waste and
pollution per year than there was the
previous year because the whole system
is growing exponentially so even if the
recycling is growing it's actually not
growing enough to even keep up with
Demand right so
um what I'm saying is now let's come
bring that back to the memetic space
which is where I was there are
both evolution of values where people
are wanting to Think Through
catastrophic risk existential risk
planetary well-being of everybody long
term
so that's good
but there is also
cultural kind of regress where people
are getting narrower value systems with
more antipathy towards other people they
share the planet with that have narrower
value systems on the other side and left
right polarization in the US is one
classic example
and
um so the point is cultural
Enlightenment is not impossible but it's
also not a given
right the kind of the kind of memetic
shift and this is obviously I think a
big part of why you do
the public education medic work that you
do is because of having a sensibility
about
um is
is it possible to support the
development and evolution of World Views
and people in ways that can propagate
and create good
um well you're saying it much more
benevolently honestly it's just selfish
that I'm just super super curious about
all these topics and by luck some other
people care to listen and follow along
and I just get to elucidate myself it's
so fun it bangs on every cylinder and
some other people seem to like it I hope
that what I'm doing is something
positive I hope that it's not producing
more harm I'm not even considering this
is sent over the internet and it's using
up energy and okay what you just
what you just said takes somewhere that
I wanted to go that's very interesting
so we're talking about alignment and is
a
is a particular alignment is a
particular say human intention lined
with the collective well-being of
everybody or even their own long-term
future
at the base of the alignment problems is
that we are not aligned with the other
parts of our own self
right so from a kind of jungian Parts
conflict point of view
um motivation is complex because there's
different parts of us that have
different motivations and
one way of thinking about psychological
Health the parts integration view is the
degree to which those different parts
are in good communication with each
other and see synergistic strategies to
meet their needs that don't require that
part of self's motivation harming
another part of self but they're
actually doing synergetic stuff so the
whole of self pulls in the same
direction
if you think of like the parts of self
as sled dogs they can be pulling in
opposite directions you get nowhere
they're all true for themselves so we
can see psychological health and ill
health is how conflicted are the parts
of ourselves versus how synergistic are
they synergistic does not mean
homogeneous doesn't mean we just have
one motive it means that the various
motives find synergistic alignment
rather than exactly like our bodies are
synergistic our heart is not the same as
the liver exactly now
in your heart
is not going to optimize itself it
delivers long-term harm
even though on its own you could say it
has a different incentive it is part of
an interconnected system where that
actually doesn't really make sense but a
cancer cell will optimize itself or the
the its both itself how much sugar it
consumes and its reproduction Cycles at
the expense of things around it and in
doing so it actually is on a
self-terminating curve because it ends
up killing the host and then killing
itself
and so the cancer that does not want to
bind its consumption and regulation
aligned with the pattern of the whole
ends up actually doing better in the
short term meaning consuming more and
producing more and then there's a
maximum number of cancer cells right
before the body dies and they're all
dead so there is a if something is
inextricably interconnected with the
rest of reality like the hard and liver
or the various cells but it forgets that
or doesn't understand that and optimizes
itself at the expense of the other
things it can be on what looks like a
short-term winning path but that
self-terminates would be an evolutionary
cul-de-sac
and I would argue that the collective
action failures of humanity as a whole
are pursuing an evolutionary cul-de-sac
and so one way of thinking about this we
say we aren't even that aligned with
ourselves we think of motive
it's in we like to think of leaders what
is Putin doing or what is Biden or she
are doing in in a particular thing what
is their motive
or what is uh the
founder of an AI lab motive motive will
always be that each of the parts of the
self has a different motive right so
typically like some unconscious part of
me
still wants to
get the amount of Parental approval that
I didn't get and then projecting that on
the world through some idea of success
or to prove that it's enough
or whatever and
um some part of me is just directly
motivated by money some evolutionary
part is motivated by Opera maximizing
mate selection opportunities some part
of me genuinely wants to do good
some
um part of me wants intellectual
congruence right and so it's
there can absolutely be a burn it all
down part right
um and this is why Shadow Works
important right which is look at and
talk to all of these parts
um and see how to get them to move
forward together this is basically
governance at the level of the self
so
um I don't know if you ever watched and
this might be because we're long even
though there's so much left to discuss a
decent place for us to wrap up on
alignment
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy